اذا ما أقدمت روسيا على غزو أوكرانيا
سيكون الرد حاسم وسريع
هكذا ضحك الروس وسخروا
من تهديدات أمريكا.
ما الذي جعل روسيا واثقة إلى هذه الدرجة
أن أمريكا لن تتدخل في أوكرانيا؟
أمريكا تسحب رعاياها من أوكرانيا،
جو بايدن يقول إن أمريكا
لن تدخل حربا ضد روسيا؟
لماذا يا هذا؟
وماذا عن التهديد والوعيد؟
هل تأكدت أمريكا أن روسيا ستغزو أوكرانيا
خلال الأيام القليلة المقبلة؟
ولماذا تتهم روسيا الغرب ببث الأكاذيب؟
متى ستنطلق الحرب بين روسيا وأوكرانيا؟
وكيف استعدت روسيا لهذا الغزو؟
وما هو موقف الدول الأوروبية من ذلك؟
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن يقول،
إن الأمور قد تتدهور بسرعة في أوكرانيا
في حال اندلاع الحرب،
وأنه يجب على المواطنين مغادرتها في الحال،
وأضاف بايدن في مقابلة تلفزيونية:
أنه لن يرسل قوات عسكرية إلى أوكرانيا،
لإجلاء الرعايا الأمريكيين
إذا حصل هناك غزو روسي،
ونفى وجود أي سيناريو للإقدام على تلك الخطوة،
قائلا إنه عندما يبدأ الأمريكيون
والروس في إطلاق النار على بعضهم البعض
فإن الأمر سيكون حربا عالمية ،،
وأضاف بايدن،
على المواطنين الأمريكيين المغادرة الآن
فنحن نتعامل مع أحد أكبر الجيوش في العالم.
فهل اقتربت الحرب حقا؟
جاء الرد سريعا من روسيا،
برفضها هذه المرة كما رفضت في المرات السابقة
هذه الادعاءات أنها تحضر لهجوم عسكري
على أوكرانيا، وقالت أن تلك الاتهامات
ذريعة لنشر البنية التحتية العسكرية
للناتو قرب الحدود الروسية،
فمن الذي يقول الحقيقة بينهما يا ترى؟
وبذات اللهجة الأمريكية
طالبت دول عديدة (بينها بريطانيا والنرويج وكندا)
مواطنيها مغادرة أوكرانيا فورا
بسبب دواع أمنية،
ليحدد البيت الأبيض وقت غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا،
أنه سيحدث خلال الألعاب الأولمبية،،،
تصريحات من هنا وردود من هناك،
ما كل هذه الجلبة في المواقف وردود الفعل؟!!!
روسيا لم تصمت أمام تصريحات البيت الأبيض
ووصفت تصريحاته بالهيستيرية
وماذا بعد هذا كله؟
هل من حرب عالمية ثالثة؟
بعد التهديدات الأمريكية شديدة اللهجة،
بخيار الرد العسكري على روسيا،
خرجت واشنطن لتحذر رعاياها الموجودين
في أوكرانيا من البقاء في البلاد،
وأطلقت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
ذاك النداء لمواطنيها في أوكرانيا،
لحثهم على مغادرة أراضي أوكرانيا فورا،
خوفا من عمل عسكري روسي مزعوم،
وهنا هولندا وأستراليا ونيوزلندا واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية
يطالبون رعاياهم أيضا بترك أوكرانيا على الفور،،
حتى أن إسرائيل أعلنت أنها سحبت دبلوماسيتيها
وعائلاتهم من أوكرانيا،.
وبينما تسحب روسيا قنصلياتها الديبلوماسية من أوكرانيا،
فهي تثبت عمليا أن الغزو سيحدث قريبا،
على الرغم من نفيها ذلك،..
المفوضية الأوروبية لم تجلِ راعيها
على عكس ما يحدث مع بقية دول العالم،.
خرج بيتر ستانو المتحدث باسم الشؤون الخارجية
للمفوضية الأوروبية،
وقال:
نحن لا نجلي أحداً. في الوقت الحاضر
أتيحت الفرصة للعاملين غير الأساسيين
للعمل عن بعد من خارج البلاد".
....
بريطانيا تدخلت وأجرت محادثات مع الروس
لحل الأزمة دون الدخول في الحرب،
وزير الدفاع البريطاني يقول بعد المحادثات:
"عندما يقولون لي إنهم لن يقوموا بغزو أوكرانيا
فإننا نأخذ ذلك على محمل الجد،
لكننا وكما قلت أيضاً سننظر إلى الإجراءات المصاحبة لذلك".
فهل يغدو الأمر محض تصريحات
بينما الغزو قادم لا محالة؟
(الرد الغربي)
عقد اجتماع عن بعد بين الدول الأوروبية وأمريكا،
وهناك أكد المجتمعون أن روسيا
ستتلقى عقوبات اقتصادية قاسية جدا
إذا ما قررت غزو أوكرانيا،
هذه العقوبات ستطال قطاعَي المال والطاقة،
إضافة إلى صادرات التكنولوجيا المتطورة".
على الأرض هناك تحشيد عسكري روسي
على الحدود الأوكرانية،
روسيا تنفي أي خطط عدوانية على أوكرانيا
والغرب يبحثون عقوبات اقتصادية على روسيا،
بينما تظل روسيا تؤكد مرارا أنها لن تسمح بتوسع
حلف الناتو في أراضيها...
ومع الانسحابات التكتيكية للرعايا الأوروبية
في أوكرانيا، وهذه ليست علامة خير أبدا،
فما هو رأيكم متابعينا؟
كيف ستنتهي هذه الأزمة؟
هل تنتهي بحرب عالمية ثالثة؟